Anyone who lives in a major city knows that
traffic is one of those niggling, persistent
annoyances.
And a new study has identified a potential
cause: you’re not keeping the right distance
from the car behind you.
Which sounds like it can’t be your problem
since you can’t control the guy that’s
staying uncomfortably close to your bumper.
True.
But mathematical models show that if every
car on the road kept the same distance between
the car in front of AND behind it, traffic
would move seamlessly and potentially even
twice as fast!
But of course it’s not that simple.
Traffic is a great example of EMERGENT PROPERTY,
a philosophical term used to describe the
phenomenon of many small things compiling
to create something bigger.
With traffic, it’s the many individuals
cars together forming a complex traffic mess.
That’s because humans bring a lot of variables
to the mix.
A driver is usually — and rightly — most
focussed on the car she’s following, but
if she brakes hard the car behind her will
have to brake a little harder.
If she gets close to another car the density
in that one area will cause a slowdown.
Mathematical models have shown that, basically,
at a certain density there are enough variables
brought by human reaction time and individual
driving habits to cause a traffic jam.
We have a little on that right here.
Interestingly, this is a human problem.
Ants don’t experience traffic jams; they
move as quickly in small groups as they do
en masse.
Bats are the same.
They fly in large groups, each one tracking
the bats around him with echolocation.
They play follow the leader, even if that
leader is in the back of a pack, in an impressive
display of group coordination.
But we’re not a colony, we’re individuals!
Yeah, except that self-driving cars could
bring this colony-like behaviour to humans.
A simple solution the new research offers
is sensors to improve bilateral control in
cars.
Current adaptive cruise controls monitors
the car ahead of you…
providing it’s not miles down the freeway.
A similar rear-facing sensor would be an easy
change to that same system.
Looking back is really no harder than looking
forward, and we wouldn’t even need to change
the roads.
The result would be well worth it.
Not only could we reduce the stress of rush
hour driving, minimizing start-stop traffic
would cut CO2 emissions and help you save
fuel… and also make driving safer.
It could really be a win-win-win all around.
For more insight into the science all around
you, be sure to subscribe.
And speaking of weird traffic patterns, is
anything truly random?
Jules dove into that one right here.
Fun driving fact: driving while blindfolded
is, weirdly, explicitly illegal in the state
of Alabama…